okay hello thank you for coming it's
wonderful to be here in Winnetka at the
legendary book stall run by the
legendary Roberta Rubin when Jane Addams
started Hull House in 1889 Winnetka was
the boondocks it was where people in
Chicago had their weekend homes Jane
Addams is dear friend Mary Rose a Smith
had a home here and Jane used to come
here on the weekends sometimes to visit
Mary's family and in the nice weather
she would cycle bicycling was all the
rage in the 1890s for liberated women
but Jane was so hopelessly uncoordinated
that she could only manage a bicycle
built for two because she needed a
friend to do most of the spinning she
couldn't cope with it on her own it's
hard for me to imagine jane addams on a
bicycle
because she was not only because she was
so hopelessly uncoordinated but because
she was so much a 19th century woman
though she lived three decades into the
20th century she remained a 19th century
woman a pre-modern and I think that
that's very important to understanding
her and to understanding her commitment
to the poor she grew up at a time when
religion was paramount in people's lives
when God was as real as characters in
Dickens when heaven was a place that you
went to to be reunited with your loved
ones at the end of your own life it was
also a time when women had no status in
society except as morally superior
beings who were keepers of the world's
morality and I think this is very
important in Jane Addams his commitment
to the poor and her social conscience
that she had at a very young age the
idea of writing about Jane Addams first
occurred to me when I moved here with my
family in 1991 from New York
and I read 20 years at Hull House Jane
Addams is autobiography as a way of
introducing myself to Chicago history
and I was immediately taken with her
spirit and immediately attracted to her
as a human being and I thought about
writing about her I'd written two
previous biographies and I originally
set out to write a full scale biography
of her but I ended up writing a book
only about her early life it ends in
1899 and the reason I did that was
because when I got deeper into the vast
archive of material at the University of
Illinois I was mostly interested in the
material about her early life first of
all this material was fresh it most of
it had been discovered after the last
biography of Jane was written in the
early 1970s and also it fit into my
chief interest as a writer which is
sensibility primarily what makes people
who they are what forces and people
shaped them who are they before they
become people in history I wanted to
rescue her from her pedestal as a
saintly reformer and portray her as a
flesh-and-blood person somebody who
lived and breathed and walked the
streets of Chicago she was identified by
people who knew her very early on as
somebody special as somebody unique she
her mother died when she was 2 and
that's perhaps why she identified so
strongly with her father who was a
paragon of virtue in his own right he
was a very prosperous mill owner he was
a state senator who knew Abraham Lincoln
he was a man known for his unfailing
integrity in every aspect of his life
and I think because her mother died so
young she identified with him very
closely she clung to him and he clung to
her of all of his children she was the
one who most resembled him especially in
intellect she was the the brightest
certainly of all his children but at the
same time
was a very sickly little girl she
suffered from what was known at the time
as Potts disease which had been known
since the ancients as a child killer it
was in Jane's case a tuberculosis of the
spine that made her back crooked and
that gave her an ungainly walk and that
forced her to hold her head to the side
and she thought of herself as an ugly
duckling
so she carried that image of herself
into her adult life and never really
shed it but by the time she got to
college at Rockford Female Seminary it
was clear that this was somebody special
who was headed for special things and at
Rockford College she met Ellen star
Ellen gates star who was this very
artistic prickly romantic high-strung
farm girl from Illinois with whom she
later went on to found her house and I'm
gonna read you a bit from the section of
my book on Rockford at Rockford Jane's
powerful presence quickly became
apparent one source of that power was
her extreme reserve in the parlance of
the era she didn't give taffy that is
she refused to indulge in the hollow
flattery and sentimental flirting that
was common among girls in Victorian
times her cool intellect was alluring
but there was something else about her
an aura emanating from her strong sense
of self that caused her to stand out she
knew she had a destiny her life would
not be ordinary and it created a little
light around her elevating her above the
crowd Jane became the idol of the other
girls they asked for her picture begged
to visit her during vacations and
elected her class president one student
Sarah Anderson told Jane that she relied
on her help and friendship as I do on
the Sun as I do on divine health and I
feel just as confident of your never
failing me another student Helen
Harrington later said that Jane's room
was an available refuge from all
perplexities and yet another recalled
however mopey it might be elsewhere
there was intellectual ozone in
Janesville Cinna T throughout though
Jane always held part of herself back
fearing to become too intimate with
anyone when she learned Ellen Starr
would not return to Rockford Jane Rose
her in the summer of 1878 I am
disappointed to think that our social
intercourse is probably over for all
time
it is queer though but effect that I am
glad when I know some people just so
much and then stop to people honestly
going ahead are better if they don't
meet too much and don't descend the
condition which high friendship demands
Jane was at the top of all her classes
and she was obsessive about following
the school's rigid conduct code to
prevent tardiness miss SIL the stern
president of rockford advised the young
women to see to it that at least one
other girl beside yourself is on time
most of the girls the Rockford seminary
magazine reported decided to be
responsible for Jane Addams Jane always
took the lead in settling disputes with
Miss SIL the old cow as some students
called her and she wasn't above having
some fun Victorian style sometimes late
at night the girls would gather for
parties in Jane's room after tacking a
blanket over the transom to hide the
lamplight they boiled candy cooked
oysters and popped corn in a wood stove
fried eggs and buttered boxes of paper
held over the oil lamps and ate cashews
from a tent picking them out with their
hairpins sometimes the girls read Romeo
and Juliet outloud other nights they
debated Darwin's theories or discussed
one of Carlile's books
Jane's avidity for new experience led
her as it has college students in other
eras to experiment with drugs one
morning she and four friends swallowed
crushed opium pills hoping to induce
hallucinations that would help them
better understand confessions by the
English essayist and opium addict De
Quincey which they planned to read once
the drug took effect instead they became
sick and disoriented a young teacher who
found them sprawled on the floor gave
them ipecac and a medic and sent them to
their rooms as Jane recalled with a
stern command to appear at family
worship after supper whether we were
able to or not the following year Jane
initiated a junior exhibition to which
her class also invited the public and
the press the girls composed a class
and designed their own class stationery
featuring a picture of wheat and their
motto bread givers which Jane told her
sister Alice is the primitive meaning of
the word lady on the evening of April
20th 1879 the 17 juniors entered the
chapel and walked to the front forming a
semicircle to sing their class song then
Jane as class president delivered an
address her speech criticizing the
dominance of men in society drew on
ideas that were current at the seminary
and increasingly being discussed in the
culture at large
she said that over the last 50 years
women's education had passed from
accomplishments in the arts of pleasing
to the development of intellectual force
and her capabilities for direct labor
woman she reassured her audience wishes
not to be a man nor like man but she
claims the same right to independent
thought in action the ideas in the
speech though strongly expressed were
fairly typical for the first generation
of American college women Jane and her
friends knew they had come of age at a
fortuitous historical moment that never
before had there been such opportunities
for their sex for the first time in
history women had the chance to have
active lives devoted to work not family
that in itself was an achievement of
course most women found the price of
such independence too high it meant
giving up marriage and motherhood and it
often led to conflicts with disapproving
parents and siblings
what's more the employment opportunities
were limited teaching medicine and
missionary work were about the only
options and there was little hope of
earning much money educated women had to
stay in their separate spheres since
there was great prejudice against women
competing directly with men even in such
innocuous areas as College debating
contests in the fall of 1880 of men from
Knox College in Galesburg Illinois tried
to block Jane and other female debaters
from participating in the State
oratorical contest the men opposed women
Ora Tours not only because they thought
it unseemly for the sexes to argue in
public so did the era's etiquette books
but also apparently because they were
jealous
the year before a female student from
Mackenzie College had been voted first
by one of the judges and the men had
complained suspecting the judge had
inflated the woman's score out of
chivalry the judge angrily denied it
gentlemen
i graded the girl first because she was
a perfect orator and had a perfect
oration I know what oratory is for I
have heard Henry Clay many a time Daniel
Webster many a time he snapped the girl
had the only oration of the evening
Yeats one of the male competitors had a
speech and the rest of you had essays
but when Jane showed up at Knox College
a male student on the welcoming
committee later admitted the boys were
scared for fear the judges would award
you the prize just because you were a
girl as it turned out Jane was the only
woman orator competing that year the
first time Rochefort had entered the
contest she felt as though she was
representing not only her school but the
progress of women's cause her classmates
boo moaning as Jane put it her
intolerable habit of dropping my voice
at the end of a sentence in the most
feminine apologetic way worried that
she'd lose they were right Jane came in
fifth exactly in the dreary middle
second place was awarded to at all
earnest looking Illinois college student
William Jennings Bryan the subject of
their orations is unknown Bryan who has
a congressman a presidential candidate
and a Secretary of State would go on to
become one of the most famous orator
Zinn American history spent his $50
prize money on an engagement ring for
his sweetheart so that was Jane's
College oratorical career after
Rochefort she returned home to her
parents house in little Cedarville
Illinois but she did not fit easily into
the role of adult daughter at home she
didn't know what she was going to do
with herself she knew she didn't want to
get married that was out of the question
and she was bored being a spinster aunt
but she didn't have many other choices
she thought she might like to be a
doctor the profession had been opened up
somewhat to women since the Civil War
and she tried medical school but she
dropped out after three months
and her dropping out of medical school
coincided with her father's death well
actually her father died first and then
she dropped out of medical school and it
was the beginning of a very long severe
depression that lasted for eight years
there was no such thing as psychology in
those days there was no Freud there was
no Prozac her stepmother took her to
this strange but very prominent doctor
named s-swear mitchell who also treated
Edith Wharton and Charlotte Perkins
Gilman and some other major women of the
day he was a specialist and female
neurasthenia which is depression and his
method of treating depression was to
isolate these women not let them see any
loved ones and not let them read not let
them so not let them talk to anybody and
force-feed them have heavy dairy
products and of course most of them
became much worse after this treatment
including Jane Addams she left the
clinic worse off than when she'd gone in
and she indeed may have spent her entire
life as another Victorian invalid had
she not gone on a grand tour of Europe
well a second grand tour of Europe the
first one she went on with her
stepmother and that didn't help her that
also fed her depression but the second
grand tour of Europe with her dear
friend Ellen star with no but nobody's
mother around and she discovered Toynbee
Hall which was the world's first
settlement in the Whitechapel slum of
London
Toynbee Hall represented a radically new
model for helping the poor until the
1880s and stretching back to the
beginning of Western society most
charities and philanthropic endeavors
were based on systems for giving relief
to the unfortunate in the form of money
food clothes and other services as the
centuries passed countless groups came
and went to help the full spectrum of
needy cases the young the old the sick
the blind and the infirm but by the mid
19th century thoughtful people began to
question the effectiveness of
traditional charity drawing the lines of
philosophical and social dispute that
are still alive today support for
traditional charity
grounded in the biblical dictate the
poor ye have always with you the most
that could be hoped for was to relieve
their distress but critics of
traditional charity believe the root
causes of poverty could be alleviated
with new approaches in fact doling out
relief these critics argued seem to
encourage the poor to be more dependent
what's more the religious zeal
underpinning traditional charity seemed
out of touch with the brutality of 19th
century urban misery William Booth
founder of the Salvation Army was often
singled out for particular disdain booth
was a ranting preacher of the
neighborhood whose one notion of
relieving distress consisted in giving
enormous breakfast to the poor and
regaling them meanwhile with revivalist
effusions the settlement in Whitechapel
was named after arnold toynbee a
charismatic social philosopher who'd
suffered a nervous collapse after
delivering an impassioned lecture on
social justice he died two months later
at age 32 soon afterward an Anglican
Church man
Samuel Barnett raised money to buy an
old industrial school for boys near his
Church in Whitechapel
he had the school torn down and in its
place built a neo Tudor mansion with
Gables diamond pane windows a lecture
hall and a dining room decorated with
the Oxford and Cambridge crests Barnett
installed 15 or so male residents all
recent university graduates who paid a
modest sum and board and who had been
chosen out of a field of applicants to
live there for variant varying periods
of a few months to a few years they
pursued paying jobs on the outside but
devoted their free time to community
service so Jane decided that she was
going to do the same thing in Chicago
only her settlement would be for women
not for men well the volunteer esident
would be women not men and this was what
the first days at Hull House were like
on September 19th 1889 Jane and Ellen
awoke after their first night at 3:35
Halsted Street to an empty Silent House
they dressed quickly in their separate
bedrooms and met in the dining room for
breakfast as they set at the oak table
sipping tea from blue china cups
roosters crowing wafted through the open
window and in the distance a sawmill
word it was the last peaceful hour they
would have four months no sooner had
they finished breakfast then a group of
mischievous boys no doubt trying to
scare the two upper-class women who'd
invaded their neighborhood began
bombarding the house with stones one of
which broke a freshly washed parlour
window then the doorbell rang news of
the young woman's project had intrigued
many of the neighborhoods adults and
over the next weeks dozens of immigrants
called at the house sweatshop workers
washer women maids factory laborers
street cleaners taxi drivers and
peddlers some with their entire families
in tow stopped in the transfigured few
as Jane called the most ambitious
foreigners those who are eager to shed
their old ways and to assimilate signed
up for the clubs classes and lectures
Jane and Ellen had advertised in the
various ethnic newspapers the Russian
Jewish taxi driver who dropped by one
evening when Ellen was at the door was
typical he spoke English in a most
formal manner
Ellen reported to her parents and
informed us that he always made it a
study to be as much of a gentleman as he
could he succeeds to a certain degree
and we signified our willingness in
polite terms to give him any assistance
in our power some adults in the
neighborhood however were hostile to the
newcomers one day a man Jane passed in
the street spat in her face though Jane
and Ellen had made sketchy plans over
the summer modeling their settlement on
torn B Hall they had no definite program
in mind and essentially they made it up
as they went along a housekeeper Mary
Keiser had moved in with them and the
settlements first resident Anna
Farnsworth would join the household
before Christmas meanwhile despite their
worries and the skepticism of some of
their supporters they had assembled a
small army of volunteers to help them
most were educated young women from
Chicago's prominent families who were
unmarried and had time on their hands
many of these young women had gone to
the same elite Chicago schools and lived
in the same fashionable neighborhoods
and they traveled back and forth to Hull
house and their parents carriages from
the start the settlement was a refuge
for
neighborhood children whose harsh lives
were often cut short by industrial
accidents and the many epidemics that
raged through their squall at homes as
yet there was no compulsory education
law in Illinois and only about a third
of the children under 14 in a city with
24 children and a waiting list of 70 a
society girl Jenny Dale was the teacher
she arrived every morning at 9:00 when
as Jane later remarked miniature
Italians Hebrews French Irish and
Germans assemble in our drawing-room and
nothing seems to excite admiration in
the neighborhood so much as the fact
that we put up with them in the
afternoons the children played outside
making sand pies on the pillar to porch
our puling wheeled toys of the inclined
walk for the older children Jane and
Ellen initiated an ambitious educational
program adding classes and clubs every
week to meet the neighborhood's growing
demands some of the classes were
utilitarian and educational others were
broadly cultural within weeks children
of all ages and ethnic backgrounds were
flocking to the settlement Friday
afternoon we have little girls in every
room of the house and Tuesdays we are
overwhelmed with boys almost as much
Jane wrote her sister Alice older boys
who worked as bootlicks street cleaners
and factory Labour's came in the evening
they're harder to manage Jane reported
though they've given up spitting tobacco
or keeping on their hats to things that
we almost despaired of curing them of
Monday afternoon was devoted to a sewing
class for 120 Italian girls taught by a
volunteer who spoke Italian wearing
dowdy print dresses the dust of the
heels of their heavy cowhide boots the
girls sat on chairs and the parlors
surrounded by photographs of Jean
Francois Malaya's edgings of peasant
women and children at 5:00 p.m. they
trooped into the dining room where a
huge dish pan overflowing with marigolds
sat on the oak sideboard
Jane stood nearby and as each girl
walked past handed her a small bouquet
in 1894 Jane and Ellen transformed a
vacant lot near Hull House into a
playground it was the first one in
Chicago and the neighborhood children
were ecstatic over it before the
facility was even opened a group of
youngsters had dug out the sand around
the playgrounds chain-link fence and
crawled underneath to get inside
Jane and Ellen were as concerned with
uplifting the adults in the neighborhood
as they were with helping the children
and to this end they'd organized an
impressive schedule of programs during
the first year of the settlement a group
of women came one night a week to view
colored slides of florentine art another
night a group largely made up of men
came for the working people social
science club they heard a 40-minute
address on topics such as child labor
and the Chicago police followed by an
hour of discussion some late 20th
century historians have criticized Jane
for encouraging her Hull House neighbors
to embrace the culture language manners
and dress of the anglo-saxon
establishment at the time however
multiculturalism was not an aspiration
multiculturalism was a widely regretted
fact and immigrants best hope for
American success was to fit in as soon
as possible a Chicago newspaper cartoon
from the 1890s depicts this ideal
hull-house evolution a series of six
drawings shows the transformation of two
immigrants a man and a woman from
disheveled slack-jawed new arrivals to
prosperous neatly attired citizens in
the first picture the couple are
extremely ethnic looking with large
noses and dark hair and eyes they appear
increasingly anglo-saxon as the pictures
progress until the final drawings they
look like the wasp Paragons and
illustrations by Charles Dana Gibson
so that gives you an idea of something
of what hull-house was like in the the
first few days and how quickly it grew
and grew and grew until within a short
time it had occupied 13 buildings on
this one square block on Halsted Street
but Jane didn't live there for long
before she realized that things were not
really going to improve until she got
involved in reform activities what was
needed was not just classes for the
immigrants but citywide reforms national
reforms even that would really affect
their lives in a direct way
the first thing she wanted to do was get
rid of or one of the first things she
wanted to do was get rid of the 19th
wards horribly corrupt alderman Johnny
powers though she couldn't vote because
she was a woman she wasn't going to let
that stand in her way
and she masterminded three campaigns to
try to get rid of him and in this effort
she was aided by her dear wife companion
Mary Rose a Smith who provided financial
support and emotional support and to
whom Jane Addams consider herself
married for 40 years the question is was
Jane Addams a lesbian she never slept
with a man she was completely
uninterested in having an emotional
relationship with a man or a physical
relationship with a man all the men in
her life
from her brother to her for her
stepbrother and her brother
brothers-in-law were troublesome beings
who suffered from mental illness and
alcoholism in one case one of them was a
terrible philanderer so she didn't have
the greatest experience with men and her
own immediate family with the exception
of her father whom she revered her
relationship with Mary Smith is very
difficult to discern because it was
conducted with such scrupulous privacy
that it's almost impenetrable Jane
Addams destroyed most of Mary's letters
Wood
you might have given a clue but the
bottom line is that they loved each
other deeply and stayed together for 40
years and it was a relationship that was
the most important one of Jane Addams
his life and without it she she
certainly could not have done the work
that she did nor could she have kept
whole-house going because Mary gave her
vast sums of money to keep it going the
last section I'm going to read is from
her fight to get rid of Johnny powers
the horrible loathsome Johnny powers as
the date of the April 1898 election
approached Jane once again mobilized
forces to fight powers guiding the 19th
Ward Improvement Club in its search for
a candidate to run as an independent the
club finally settled on Simeon Armstrong
an Irish Catholic former laborer and
store clerk who'd struggled through
night school to become a lawyer Jane
helped persuade the wards Republican
organization to endorse Armstrong so as
not to divide the opposition vote then
she imported a University of Chicago
economics professor William Hill to make
a study of the voters of the Ward and to
run Armstrong's campaign she also
organized her friends to go after the
various ethnic voters Senor maestro
Valerio the former editor of l'Italia
came in from Alabama where he and his
wife had relocated to start a farming
commune to campaign among the Italians
Mary Kenney a union organizer who was
living in New York with her husband Jack
Sullivan a former seaman and labor
organizer moved into Hull House for a
few weeks to help win over the Irish
Catholics other residents worked until
midnight every night addressing
envelopes and stuffing them with
Armstrong's campaign literature Jane
gave speeches and on many days sallied
forth to raise money for Armstrong's
campaign
shivering against the lake winds as she
waited for streetcars and returning late
in the day her skirts muddy and her
handbag full of checks
Jane recognized that powers would be
hard to unseat in a speech to the
ethical culture Society in January which
was later published in the prestigious
international journal of ethic
she attacked powers without naming him
and astutely analyzed his hold over the
19th Ward to the 19th Ward's poor
unsophisticated voters Jane explained
powers embodied the promise of the new
world he had arrived in America with
nothing and within a few short years had
become rich and powerful his
constituents did not consider him
corrupt the Irish in particular she said
through long custom at home had come to
look upon those who govern as rack rent
landlords those who demand the highest
rents that is and many had come to this
country not only desiring to feed at the
public crib but considering it perfectly
legitimate to do so but the Alderman's
greatest power she noted was in being a
friendly neighbor in bailing
constituents out of jail providing jobs
at one time powers boasted that he had
2600 people in his ward on the public
payroll 1/3 of all the voters paying for
funerals distributing turkeys at
Christmas indeed what headway can the
notion of civic purity of honesty of
administration make against this big
manifestation of human friendliness this
stucking survival of village kindness
Jane asked the notions of the Civic
reformer are negative and impotent
before it they give themselves over
largely to criticisms of the present
state of affairs to writing and talking
of what the future may be but their
goodness is not dramatic it is not even
concrete and human the speech was one of
the first attempts to explain the source
of boss power and it put Jane in the
national spotlight for the first time
she repeated the speech several times in
Chicago and once in Michigan and it was
widely accepted in newspapers and
magazines across the country despite
Jane's astute analysis of powers
influence professor Hill's analysis gave
Armstrong a good chance to win of the
wards approximately 10,000 voters 2,500
were Irish 1000 were German 3,000 were
Jews and 2,000 were Italians Native
Americans Bohemians and French made up
the rest Hill estimated that Armstrong
would capture all 3,500 of the wards
Republican votes
divided among the various ethnic groups
and most of the Italian vote and that he
would split the 2500 Irish votes that
usually went to powers that combination
alone would be enough to elect Armstrong
but he'll also counted on a thousand
additional votes from the Bohemians the
Jews and the Germans but powers was not
about to risk defeat particularly since
he was expecting a large payoff the
corrupt traction King Charles urkki's
was planning to ask the City Council for
an ordinance extending his Street
Railway franchise for 50 years Yerkes
had offered powers a substantial bribe
to ensure that the council cooperated
but at first but first powers had to be
re-elected powers realized he was in a
ferocious battle and he fought back by
now he had long abandoned any notion of
trying to win over the the spirited
do-gooders of Halsted Street and he
vowed to drive Jane Addams and Hull
House from the ward a year from now
there will be no such institution he
thundered at a reporter from the Chicago
record adding that Jane was obviously
jealous of his Charities he
unsuccessfully tried to have the ward
wejust redistricting off the eastern
predominantly Italian end where he faced
his greatest opposition also he gave his
blessing to a ladies auxilary which was
instructed to publicly criticize the
work of the Hull House women his healers
smashed the windows of shops displaying
Armstrong's picture and broke up
meetings and labor halls where political
leaders stumped for Armstrong he even
bought up a batch of abandoned cottages
and installed regiments of tramps to
register to vote
Jane paid a group of detectives to
investigate the fraud but it is so hard
to prove anything with everybody so
corrupt
she wrote Mary Smith who was involved in
more with her mother Jane was spending
more money than she planned Hull House
supporter Lydia Ward coonley had given
her a hundred and thirty seven dollars
and she was trying hard not to use the
hundred dollars Mary had sent her for
some other expense but she wasn't sure
she could hold out Jane was cheered when
$1,000 came in from the editor of the
railway age a trade journal meanwhile
Mary O'Sullivan was making headway with
Catholics four months pregnant and
wearing an old dress of Mary Smith's
she spent long hours talking to the most
powerful Jesuit priests in the ward the
priests for the most part supported
powers and O'Sullivan discovered that
their opposition to the hull-house
Kennett candidate sprung in part from
jealousy of the success of Hull House
and they also had a sense of obligation
to powers who routinely fed the church's
coffers still the priests seemed to be
responding to of Sullivan's entreaties
for the first time I am beginning to
have a little real hope Jane wrote Mary
on March 20th but she was exhausted as
today pained to run a successful
campaign could be hugely expensive and
required constant hat in hand begging
which Jane found discomforting her
relentless schedule also included
fundraising for Hull House overseeing
all the settlements programs and
building projects plus speaking
engagements on top of that she was
wounded by the relentless criticism
Armstrong and the Reformers received
throughout the campaign from the Chicago
Chronicle and newspaper with streetcar
interests The Chronicle knew how to play
to the lingering prejudices against
do-gooders huffing that the Reformers
professed to give psychological account
of the people of the Ward as though they
were a species apart to be looked upon
with patronizing pity the morning mail
also brought virulent attacks most of
them from men one of the most obscene
signed a voter arrived in the middle of
January did it ever occur to you while
on a tour of inspection of such places
where low depraved men with criminal
records may be found you might for a
small sum induce one of such men to sell
you his pecker and balls you would then
have the privilege of casting a vote
until you can do this you are a dead one
phone tired and facing such ugly
personal attacks
Jane missed Mary terribly dearest I love
you more than I ever did for in the
midst of this horrible election and all
the rest of it I find myself depending
upon your moral fiber as never before
she wrote Mary in March she commissioned
an artist
Alice Kellogg Tyler to paint Mary's
portrait and one night at 10:30 after
collecting campaign funds all day
Jane slipped into the hull-house art
studio to gaze at the picture Jane found
Mary's youth and beauty to be in sharp
contrast to the dirty business of
campaign financing I almost sent back
the money you look so good and true she
told Mary on the Thursday before the
Tuesday election the entire settlement
worked until midnight on campaign
literature sitting at the dining room
tables with the voter registration lists
spread out before them they addressed
envelopes and folded flyers for 12,000
households the only break came when a
few of the women escaped to see Frau
soorma portray Nora in Ibsen's new play
a dollhouse at the theater downtown one
evening a few nights later Powers staged
a parade in the neighborhood it was the
Alderman's last supreme effort one
resident said and was very imposing
indeed as the parade marched down Polk
Street and turned north on to Halsted
the women of Hull House rushed outdoors
to watch the Jesuit church's boys
temperance band resplendent in their new
uniforms paid for by powers led the way
followed by the County Democrats dressed
in cutaways and silk top hats and
carrying canes then came a gaggle of
carriages and a crowd on foot some small
boys among them shouting down with Hull
House and others carrying banners
reading no petticoat government for us a
group of Hull House men shielded Jane
from the hecklers and blocked her view
of a large placard depicting on one side
professor Hill dangling Simeon Armstrong
from a string and on the other Jane
tearing out senior maestro valerio's
hair Election Day Tuesday April 5th with
cold and sunny
despite mayor Swift's assurances that
extra police would be on hand to enforce
the peace everything is as bad as bad
can be Jane wrote Mary the saloons are
all open by mid-morning a man had been
arrested for drawing a gun at the
polling place for the Hull House
neighborhood Hill himself was struck in
the face by a power supporter at another
polling place a policeman arrested the
culprit who managed to escape on the way
to the Maxwell Street station house when
it was all over powers had won easily
swelling his majority from the last
election to nearly 80
son of the vote he lost only one of 33
precincts the 17th home of the largest
number of Italians no doubt the vote was
the result of substantial fraud but Jane
could not prove anything
despite her expensive detectives on the
morning after the election Jane called
at 14 Walton place Mary Smith's home
Mary was still in Baltimore but Jane
chatted with Mary's father about Ward
politics and Hull House business
she felt so blue when she got back to
Halsted Street that she slipped up to
the art studio to retrieve Mary's
portrait she placed the unfinished
picture over the mantel in her bedroom
where it would be the last thing she'd
see in the evening and the first thing
in the morning it gave her she reported
to Mary a perplexing comfort there any
questions
people like Abraham Lincoln Martin
Luther King
maybe Eleanor Roosevelt who are all
great writers how do you regard her as a
writer and did the two go hand-in-hand
do you have to be a great writer
communicator to be a social activist
writing that made Jane a celebrity there
were within a few short years there were
400 settlements in America and some of
them were run by people who were as
charismatic and dynamic as Jane Addams
Mary McDowell for example who had a
wonderful settlement back of the yards
but Jane became famous because she wrote
and she started out with magazine
articles and she graduated quickly to
books most of her books seem very dated
today and that's largely because the
reforms that she was urging we take for
granted now but a couple of her books
still are very poignant and readable one
of them her favorite book and my
favorite book of hers the spirit of
youth and city streets is just very
moving it's filled with it's the book
next to 20 years at Hull House her
autobiography that's the most personal
also but I certainly think if you want
to be in the national spotlight you
either have to write or you have to
somehow get the attention of the media I
mean today it's completely different
because of television but if she hadn't
written she she would not have her fame
would not have spread beyond Chicago
papers first
placed at the University of Chicago and
were those the papers that you based her
early childhood YES on they were they've
been there for years they've been
sitting there for years and other people
have read them but no one decided to use
them for a book they were just sort of
gathering dust and it's wonderful
material that provides a look not only
at Jane Addams as childhood but also at
this dysfunctional turn-of-the-century
or Civil War era family that would have
been fascinating even if one of their
members had not grown up to be Jane
Addams yes
letters letters to and from Jane Addams
and those closest to her
those were them how did you come up with
your end notes format then how did I
come up in my your your code for your
endnotes and my code as the letters did
that you that you refer back to the
collections huh now did you invent that
yourself for hard well they're
abbreviations
yeah are the letters yes I invented it
myself being the artist for the portrait
of Mary yeah well I didn't find much
evidence of her in those early years
except as an artist I'm sure she was you
know I'm sure she pulled her weight as
everybody did I mean there were no
slackers at whole house actually taught
art classes I'm sure everybody had to do
had it not only teach but had to show
visitors around and answer the phone
when they finally got a phone
at 1991 1899 1899 my book ends now 1880
1889 right it's ten years right right
well it was one day I was sitting in the
archive at the University of Illinois
and I looked at this file cabinet they
had that had an index card on every
letter in the collection and there were
probably 75 drawers and I realized I've
been at it for three years and I'd only
gone through two drawers yeah and I was
very despairing that I would ever finish
the book but I but what really interests
me about Jane Addams was to capture her
as a person before she became a person
in history to capture her as a human
being and because I felt that was what
was missing from the record other other
people have written about Hull House and
about the history of Social Work and in
Allen Davis is wonderful 1970-something
biography he wrote about Jane Addams as
an icon and I wanted to write about her
as a person and about her childhood
influences because I felt that that was
not only what interested me the most as
a writer but it was what was missing in
the record of Jane Addams she's one of
these iconographic figures that
everybody thinks they know all about but
really no one had much of a clue as to
who she was as a woman yes she lived
almost 50 years I guess after her spell
of depression severe depression did she
have any other episodes of depression
yes but never that debilitating as when
she was a girl she just got on a
treadmill and kept going I think had she
stopped working she probably would have
would have had another nervous collapse
she would get depressed she could never
be alone she always had to have people
around she could never even when she was
writing somebody had to be there with
her and I think that that was a symptom
of of her vulnerability to depression
she was always trying to keep it at bay
yeah well stay had they had a lot in
common yeah I heard about Jane Addams
through my brother-in-law and
sister-in-law who spent a lot of time at
Hull House and so my thoughts were that
she did so much for Chicago these people
were growing up and we're so inspired by
what Hull House had to offer them to
they came to Hull House and and in
addition to going to school they came to
home well it I mean it was amazing what
she and her friends did I mean it was at
a time when there were no government
services at all and she you know there
weren't even library there wasn't even a
library in that than Health Halsted
Street neighborhood she started a
library and just a theater group
everything she just anticipated all of
the programs of the New Deal and created
the profession of Social Work and
provided a job for these hundreds of
women who otherwise wouldn't have had
anything to do either and she always
spoke of it her work as saving herself
as well as the poor she called it the
dual objective and subjective necessity
of social settlements oh really what
year was that after the turn a wintry
close to a hundred years old if they
were alive
Oh too long it took forever it took
years five years I had to read through
thousands of documents and the documents
are all handwritten and they were Xerox
copies of handwritten letters and Jane
Adams handwriting is indecipherable it
was like learning a foreign language the
Jane Addams language in order to read
the letters in fact now I picked them up
and I can't read them anymore because
I'm out of practice I have to sort of
look at them very carefully for about 20
minutes before I can read her
handwriting what would you attribute
that because penmanship was so important
in those days that's true she was in a
hurry she was in a big hurry
she was the busiest person on the face
of the earth and she was still writing
letters four or five letters a day to
her friends so she just didn't have time
to worry about her penmanship did you
find anything around college yes a lot
of stuff on the rocford years was there
Rockford College yes all the material
about miss still the old cow it was not
like college today you know a hairshirt
epoch dominated the routine it was very
austere
I think it's important to realize that
she was heavily supported by Florence
Kelly Julia Lathrop as Hamilton and that
these women for instance Florence Kelly
was really the one who who motivated her
to get out and do political action it
wasn't something that she came to easily
on her own and so when you talk only
about her it seems as if she's more
self-starting in some of these things
and I think she actually was
oh no and there's I have a long section
in my book about the women of Hull House
who influenced her by all means it was a
fascinating group of very brilliant
women Alice Hamilton in Florence Kelly
Julia Lathrop who were indispensable to
Jane Addams and a wonderful woman named
Louise de covin Bowen who was extremely
rich and who surpassed Mary Smith and
financial donations and she was Louise
Bowen who really kept it going towards
the middle towards the turn of the
century with vast infusions of cash so
Jane Addams was able to keep control
otherwise she would have lost control of
the settlement yes I did there's a
little Museum there there's a little
Museum they have some of Jane Addams as
clothes and toys it's very sweet yes the
cemetery
when did she leave uh she she left in
the 20s I think she she was quickly
eclipsed by these other women we were
just mentioning and she got into
bookbinding and she stayed up in her
apartment binding books and she was less
close to Jane Addams after the first
years but she remained until she had a
very serious spinal operation that left
her paralyzed she go a lot of useful
work and got a lot of public attention
why was it she really very effective in
getting broad public sympathy for
political and social reform I mean why
would why would a woman that was so
popular and so well-respected have such
a hard time achieving public sympathy in
the city of Chicago well in a strange
way she was more successful the farther
she got from Chicago she part of it I
think that you know as a woman who
couldn't vote it was just sort of
hopeless trying to mastermind a
political campaign I mean how could you
know nobody they couldn't vote they
couldn't they had no influence you know
among their own friends so I think that
once she started writing and became a
spokesperson for social issues
she was taken more seriously
once she reached the national stage and
became an iconographic figure and then
in middle america she was considered you
know an absolute radical you know later
on yeah yeah not at this not not at any
time like by the time World War one came
along and her ideas about peace yes she
was as long as she was as long as she
was talking about educational reform and
feeding the poor and clothing the poor
and cleaning up the slums and abolishing
sweatshops those were still sort of
womanly issues but politics was
definitely a male domain and she was
considered meddling in male affairs but
with the detachment of her writing she
could write about about politics I think
and be listened to
wasn't she part of the movement though
that created the juvenile court in Tony
and what became known as the altie home
yes but Jane Addams was not as involved
with the juvenile court as people thinks
she was I mean the juvenile the juvenile
court establishment was just a citywide
effort involving you know hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people and Jane
Addams was certainly involved but in
written really a peripheral way there
were other women at Hull House that were
more involved in it than she was but
that was definitely a successful
political battle but there were men
there were many men who were
instrumental in that and I don't think
the women could have done on their own
how was she doing with it I get the
sense that it's sort of her against
all-male kind
did she have broad you know support
among women and all these little more
isn't franchised and and therefore there
was no way that she could succeed well
no she was she was a charismatic figure
there's no doubt I mean she had
followers before she even knew she had
started a movement people worshipped her
she had male followers too they're one
of the most interesting things I found
in the papers at the University of
Illinois was a note from the first
juvenile court judge to the woman whose
name I've forgotten at the moment it's
in my book who had who was running the
juvenile court schooled a school that
was for the kids who were incarcerated
and this woman did not get along with
Jane Addams and she complained about
Jane Addams it's unclear what her
complaint was but it sounds like she
thought Jane Addams was trying to boss
her around and she complained to the
judge and the judge wrote wrote her back
saying well it's about time you women
have found out about Jane Addams because
we men have known all along essentially
you know what a bossy [ __ ] she is
and so I think that you know she was
resented by by a lot of men in power in
Chicago also that by doing good women
were continuing their historic role and
in a little project I was involved in 40
years ago I was astonished when we were
facing some political problems and I was
in this meeting in Lake Forest and they
wanted to get the Lake County Board to
move on this project and they were
asking me to get them to move and I said
look your husband's own and operate the
Republican Party just speak to your
husband's and there was just like that
because they didn't speak to their
husbands about these things and I would
expect that in Jane Addams this day that
was even more true there
been a few exceptions but I would expect
that this was a woman's endeavor and I
Sheridan and then when Jane Addams and
her followers were crossing swords with
industrialism and with unions and so on
then it became a very serious problem
because it involved and then very
directly Jane Addams was also involved
in trying to arbitrate the Pullman
Strike and she was the only woman who
testified before the US Commission
investigating the strike when it was
over there's this report that's like a
thousand two hundred pages long and
she's the only woman's voice and the
whole thing but she she would be paid
attention to mostly in her role as moral
overseer you know not as a political
power so as long as she was she would
was staying in that sphere of morality
goodness she wasn't people didn't reject
her activities but when she strayed out
of it in politics trying to fight Johnny
powers or with the juvenile court judge
whose toes she'd stepped on people
didn't like it men didn't like it
anything else